One fucking kids today,
fucking kids today.
Fucking kids.
Hasn't.
Everybody said that from the beginning
of the time.
I Bet k people were saying that shit.
You know,
it's just,
it is what it is,
right?
Every new group comes up,
they try to reestablish themselves a
smarter,
you know,
this new group coming up,
they're going to change the rules.
I don't know what's so wrong with how we
turned out,
you know?
I mean like not from a like I mean
every.
I think every generation is better than
the next in terms of how things.
This is the best times I've ever been
for most people.
Right.
But I'm saying from like a how we
handled things,
perspective things seem.
I'm like a fine human being.
You seem like a fine,
like most human beings are fine and we
were raised quite,
I don't wanna say differently but a
little better in my perspective than
what's happening now.
Like what,
what does being corrected is strange to
me.
To people that don't know the story.
Let's fill them in on your story and how
we got together.
So you're doing a Gig.
You're at Columbia,
so a few months ago,
uh,
I got this group called Asian American
Alliance at Columbia University hit me
up saying,
hey,
you know,
we're big fans of your work.
Um,
I was the first Indian ever write for
snl and so they were like,
that was a story in the Asian American
Indian community.
And so they hit me up in like may or
June,
like,
hey,
come,
we have the show in November.
It's called culture shock.
It's a big like fashion culture kind
event.
And I've done like tons of these before,
you know,
because my sister and I,
we both went down or you bought my
sister.
I'm like help put on these kinds of
shows.
So I would attend them and like I've
seen them ever since high school because
I went to high school in Parsippany,
New Jersey,
which is like a hyper diverse kind of
place at least with like Asians and
Indian people.
And like I went to a few in high school,
I got laid after one of them when I was
in high school.
So they had like a,
I lost my virginity.
So like it was like they held a special
place in my heart and so like I went
thinking,
okay,
this is going to be fun and,
and they know who they're getting in
that,
you know,
the email said that we're fans of your
work,
like we want you to come do the show.
It's about like representing Asian
identities and all that.
I'm like dope.
And that's,
I get there at like 7:30
and I walk in and I'm like okay,
I know all these kids.
I mean there are like 20 or something.
But like I know that I grew up with
these kids,
you know,
like Abigail's and critiques or
whatever.
Like I know these guys and immediately
my comic hat turns on.
I'm like okay,
the show itself,
the energy is dope.
But the show like acoustically I'm
looking okay,
there's a high ceiling,
the lighting shit,
it's not set up for like a comedy event,
but I still think okay,
this is gonna go well eight,
38,
45.
I get on stage and I'm like I do some
Columbia stuff because I went to
Columbia for like a summer program.
I started making fun of the kids a bit
and say,
do I have to give like a trigger
warning?
Almost like joking,
like,
do I have to give a trigger warning
because I know,
you know,
that's a thing.
And I say like,
be careful some of this might be sexist,
some of this might be racist,
uh,
you know,
just buckle up and one girl booze.
And I'm like,
they're booing already.
It's like two minutes in.
And I'm like,
well look,
this is the.
I literally said I just listened to the
set but on the way here.
And I said,
uh,
well buckle up,
you know,
cause this is the real world or
whatever.
And then I go into material and about.
And it's going,
well,
this is one story I want to dispel.
Like,
uh,
I will fully own a bomb if I'm bombing.
I know I'm bombing.
I will tell you that bombed before a
billion times.
I'm doing fine.
Sixty,
70 percent of the set,
17 minutes in.
I tell the joke where I say I'm
effectively.
I don't think being gay is a choice,
which is,
I don't think it is at all.
Uh,
but this is how you know,
because there's gay black people and no
one's going to choose to be gay if
they're already black.
Right?
No one's doubling down on hardship.
That's fun,
Joe.
Thank you.
No one.
No one's a funny joke.
Thank you.
No one like no black dude ever wakes up
and thinks,
you know what?
This black shit to wheezy.
I'm going to put on a Madonna Halter top
and some Jordans and tell an Indian dude
how to live his life.
That's not a choice.
That's new born that way.
And that it bombs like this.
Silence.
Really complete silence.
And then I say you're exactly who I
expected to be as a crowd.
And then I say,
uh,
I'm the only person that chooses.
This is also what wasn't printed.
That the offensive part to me.
What I think is offensive.
The next part where I say the only
person that chooses whether or not to be
gay in a daily basis is mike pence.
Right?
We can all agree that like,
I don't know if he's getting that,
but no man hates homosexuals that much
if he himself is not a homosexual,
he chooses not to be gay everyday and
that gets some laughs and applause.
And I'm like,
okay,
cool.
And then,
uh,
get back into it.
I'm rolling for about another two or
three minutes.
Um,
I started talking to some do a joke
about how my dad landed in Newark when
he immigrated to America.
Some girls from Newark,
she interrupts as todd talking for like
two minutes and that goes terribly.
It's just like I'm trying to,
I've gone fishing with her,
just trying to see if I can get back
into it.
She interrupting,
I say I heckling or is she,
I say I say a joke where I send my dad
left,
landed in Newark back when he landed,
it was called brick city because if you
hit,
if you looked at someone wrong,
they'd hit you with a brick.
Right.
Find kind of throwaway line.
This girl goes,
that's not true.
I'm like,
well,
yeah.
I'm like,
obviously I'm just kidding.
Uh,
but like I know where she's,
what she's trying to do,
I'm just trying to talk to her and I'm
going to talk about like trying to get
back into material.
Um,
and that's like probably a minute 20 or
something and then added my corner of my
left eye.
I see the three girls that invited me to
do the show initially in May or June,
like gather and like that's kind of
strange.
I still talk to this girl for like
another 30 seconds and then as I'm
concluding my talking to her because I
realized that's not going to go
anywhere.
They come on stage with microphones in
like one trench coat and they're just
like,
I feel like it's time.
It's literally to say there's been a
change.
Thank you.
To Mesh has been a change in program.
Um,
you know,
we've received from comments from
members,
um,
you know,
uh,
we think that's enough.
How long had you been on stage for a 20
something minutes at this point.
And it was one joke that did it.
So I go,
I'm like,
I'm first,
I'm,
I'm not even mad at this point.
I'm just like in shock.
I'm like,
this is like guy episode of impractical
jokers.
Islam just like,
what is,
what are you talking about?
I have to have 45 minutes left gum
slated to do an hour and like really?
Really?
And they say yeah,
there's been comments like people are
upset or offended and I'm like,
I feel like we're having a good time and
have some of the crowd cheers.
And then I'm like,
why do I gotta go and one of the girls
goes,
the tech has to leave and I look at the
tech has,
this is all on youtube.
Like someone put the Youtube video out
of this particular part and I go,
they better be leaving because I could
see,
I could see the tech people.
I'm looking at him like,
you gotTa Bounce Dude and tech people,
meaning the people that are coordinating
the electronics,
the tech cast to show exactly whoever's
running need tech.
I'm fucking pyrolosis microphones on.
What do you mean the tech has to go?
Tech people have to coming up with lies.
Yeah,
I mean I understand why she lied because
she's trying to save face and not try
it.
I guess not to embarrass me or whatever,
but I'm like,
I'm not going to believe that shit that
all three you came out,
they'd be like,
the tech has.
And then I go,
um,
is it because the tech has to leave or
because I'm saying some things that made
people uncomfortable and one of the
other girls goes,
uh,
there's,
we think there's a distinction between
being uncomfortable and being
disrespectful.
And I'm like,
don't use your big words.
But,
but in my brain I'm like,
what?
Why?
What are you talking about?
Like,
I don't think I've been disrespectful at
all.
Then there are some people who are like,
what the fuck is going on?
Majority of people are like,
And,
but like there's a pocket of the crowd
were the three,
uh,
Asian American alliance leaders and like
the rest of the crew was like waiting.
And I think some of them cheer when
they'll make the distinction between
disrespectful being uncomfortable.
I'm like,
what do you hadn't been disrespectful in
the slightest?
What are you talking about?
And then one girl goes,
we think you're not entitled to be
making some of the jokes you're making.
And I'm like,
I'm like my,
my trigger words entitled,
you know,
like I'm,
I'm thinking at this point,
I'm like,
I'm too almost in shock,
deer in headlights,
kind of like even processed anger.
I'm just like,
now I'm just trying to assess what
they're specifically saying.
Like which joke specifically.
And they're like,
we think that gay and black joke,
I'm a is particularly offensive or
whatever.
And I'm like,
and then at this point I'm like,
instead of explaining that the joke is
quite progressive,
I'm like,
I literally got that job from an
audience member at stand up New York in
like 2011.
Like I remember the conversation
distinctly because it was such like one
of these sort of,
oh shit,
that's a good bit moment.
Right?
And I tell them that and they were like,
you're talking to a guy in the crowd.
So I was onstage and I used to live in
Hell's kitchen.
I'm in New York and I'm in like the,
there's like a gay black constituency
that would always make fun of me when I
was leaving my apartment,
but like,
like ribbing me,
you know what I mean?
Right.
And so like I'm,
I'm trying to talk about that on stage
at stand up New York during like a check
spot or whatever and I'm talking to the
crowd and then there's was a gay black
guy that like heckled me and I started
talking to him and then at some point
I'm like,
this is how,
you know,
being gay can be a choice.
Right?
And He's,
he starts dying and we have like a good
rapport.
And I'm like,
oh perfect,
this is a great bit.
I just got it.
And so I tell them that and they're
like,
no,
you know,
there's been a change for you,
like you have to go.
And I'm like,
effectively,
I'm like,
you're wrong for doing what you're doing
right now.
I'm,
I'm a generation older than you guys.
I know comedy better than anybody in
this room for.
That's for God damn sure.
And I know disrespect and I,
I've been through a lot of shit,
like I know that what I'm saying right
now hasn't been offensive in the
slightest and I say you can't isolate
yourself from the real world.
Like what are you going to do when,
when some real bad shit happens in the
world,
like if someone actually does something
that's offensive,
you can't handle things this way.
If you silence someone that's not,
that's not progress or whatever.
And then they asked me if I have closing
remarks,
you have closing remarks as prepared.
So those are hard to come up with
closing remarks out of nowhere on the
spot.
I tried to save it.
I tried to save it with a bit,
you know,
and it fucking bonds.
I'm like hi.
And just unlike still talking and then
they cut my mic and I'm like,
really?
I'm like,
Really?
You cut my uh,
and then I'm like,
alright,
thank you.
Well put the mic down and bounce.
And then they try to,
they won't even let me talk to them
backstage like one one members,
we got to escort you out.
I'm like,
you guys caught me,
I'm six foot one Indian dude.
Like I don't need escort from you.
Tiny person.
Like I'll be fine.
I'm not here to fight anybody even
though I was,
this is just not the movie the escorting
you out because they want to kick you
out or are they worried about your
safety?
Like,
no,
they want to escort me out because they
want to take me out.
Right,
right,
right.
And so I go to where I have a camera
crew there because I'm trying to film
every hour that I do and I go to them
and I'm like,
what the what?
Just if you watched the youtube clip,
I'm like onstage,
like,
look at them.
I go to them,
I'm like,
and then some of the members from the
alliance try to,
uh,
talk to me.
I'm like,
we're so sorry that that happened.
Like,
you know,
that's not all of us are.
We don't know what just happened.
And I'm in my head,
I'm like thinking so much for the
alliance part of this whole thing,
right?
Like I thought we were saying people on
Flesh,
if we come from the same place.
So there's no other jokes they found
offensive.
That was the only one.
That's what they said.
There's,
there's,
there's like two or three things that
said like,
um,
articles which I made the mistake of
just reading everything.
Like don't ever do that now fucking just
what I read everything and I like this
two or three articles that say like I
was badgering,
uh,
two people in the crowd and there's like
one girl who like maybe two or three
minutes and like I talked to her for
crowd work.
Like I asked where she's from,
but she's doing whatever and that she
grew up,
she gets up,
like she stands in,
like shows herself off to the crowd.
I make fun of her for a little bit.
And then this other girl,
the one,
the newer chick that is like,
we get personal because she reveals her
father is not in her life with the
conversation just gets awkward.
It's not.
She revealed that her father is not in
her.
I'm like,
she was,
I'm talking about.
I'm talking to her like a,
um,
I was like,
what is,
what do your parents do or whatever,
and she's like,
oh.
She's like,
I don't know what my dad does.
Like,
what do you mean?
He's like,
oh,
I don't know him.
I'm like,
Oh,
you,
you don't,
he's not in your life or whatever.
He doesn't.
And she was like,
yeah.
I was like,
okay,
I can sense that she's uncomfortable now
to the point where I asked her,
I was like,
are you uncomfortable?
And she said,
no.
I'm like,
okay,
cool,
because I can make this worse.
And then like,
but I won't,
you seem like a nice person.
That's when they came out.
But the people are apologizing to me and
I'm like,
I'm now on mad now.
once I leave the stage,
I'm now I'm livid.
But um,
I know myself well enough to be like,
I'm not going to talk to anybody if I'm
angry because I'll just say some wild
shit.
Like I don't.
I felt I have bill bird Philadelphia at
a whole thing.
You know what I mean?
This just went off on all these people
for like 10 minutes,
but what the fuck is wrong with that?
But I just went,
I was like,
I gotta go,
like I'm,
I'm out and took my crew and we just,
we just walked straight out of this
fucking giant hall and,
and then like I'm waiting for my car and
people from the show or like,
like apologizing,
not just audience members know yet.
We're so sorry that was fucked up.
That shouldn't have happened.
You were doing great.
Whatever.
And then like,
uh,
I get in my uber to my next show after
this I have to do another hour,
another show.
And where are you going next?
Ucb East in lower east side from
Columbia to lower.
It's like a 30,
40 minute ride and we hop in the car and
like,
I'm like,
first of text,
my agent,
I'm like,
this just happened.
And he's like,
do not say shit until you get paid.
I'm like,
that's probably the right move.
Uh,
because I'm about to just fucking
instagram something.
Like that's a real agent.
These tech,
it was just,
do not say shit until you get paid.
I'm like,
you're right man.
And I'm just like in my head like mad
listening to like drake,
just like a guy lead enemies.
Just like fucking everything that I
think is wrong that we hear as a
narrative of like kids have solved all
this kind of shit is playing.
I'm like,
yes,
that's what it is like.
And I'm thankful that my crew was there
because I'm to,
I'm venting to them because if they
weren't there I'd be on some other shit.
And.
But as I'm checking my instagram because
I'm like,
this is definitely going to be a fucking
story on instagram at the very least.
I'm like,
people are deeming me from the show.
Like,
Yo,
we're so sorry that that happened.
That's so fucked up.
People that email me the same shit.
I'm like,
was anybody saying fuck you?
You shouldn't have been there in the
first place.
No,
no one said that to me at a one girl who
was the suite may have uh,
uh,
one of the organizers,
dme and just like yelled at me
basically.
I just,
I've ever,
I wrote to her,
thank you for your support,
like,
you know,
just like that she say she said on the
finding do my dms just blew up a is this
twitter,
instagram,
and she was my instagram's not a like a
wet from my phone,
but she was effective from your phone.
I check it in the morning and I deleted
an APP,
check it at night and then I deleted it
again.
Real.
I just fucking hate saw when I was at
snl I worked on update.
Um,
and so like I was constantly on my phone
or on twitter on is just like checking
news,
reading shit.
And like,
it,
it annoyed the shit out of me.
I hate the news.
Lo and behold,
I am the news now for a bit,
but like I fucking,
I hate the news.
It's all bullshit.
And like being in this cycle has
confirmed my belief that it's all
fucking nonsense,
but she effectively says,
uh,
I hope you learned your lesson of um,
a respecting what you were hired to do
and respecting strong young women.
Uh,
check your fucking ego.
And I was just saying I was,
I was like,
it took all of me not just be like,
just a visceral hate because I'm like,
I'm good with what,
I'm not good a lot of things,
but I can,
I can eviscerate somebody's in the
instagram DM.
Um,
and so I didn't,
I didn't say Shit to her besides thank
you for support,
but I have all these people are
messaging me like,
Yo,
we're so sorry that fucking happened.
And like,
I'm like,
all right,
I'm not totally fucked with all these
kids and I go to this show at ucb east
and like I'm taping the hours an hour so
I can't even process of what just
happened because my instinct is just
talk about this immediately but I can't
because I have to tape this hour.
And so I get off stage and the hour goes
well.
And as I'm leaving ucb east three kids
that were at the show at Columbia had
come down from Columbia and followed me
to ucb east and they came up to me and
apologize in person.
They're like,
we're so sorry.
That happened.
Like we loved your set,
like we don't know what the fuck is
going on.
And that took me,
that gave me like a beat to be like,
alright,
you know,
like maybe,
maybe everyone isn't this way.
Maybe it's just the people that have the
fucking bull horn that get to just say
whatever the fuck they want and silence
people that are like the minority,
but they're like the,
the vocal minority.
Whereas like all these people that are
like actually on my squad are not as
vocal as they can be.
They're more like quiet and apologize
and person.
And so the next day,
um,
I,
I don't think anything about it,
but like the Columbia newspaper hits me
up.
Like I got off,
I leave Columbia at 9:30,
the Colombian newspaper hits me up at
10.
Oh,
5:00
PM.
Like,
Hey,
do you have any comment?
Like,
comment,
I'm hungry it,
how's that for a comment?
Like,
well,
I'm not going to talk to you right now.
Let me fucking process what's going on
the next day.
I'm still thinking about it,
but I'm going down to open for Aziz in
Atlantic city.
And uh,
open for him and I'm telling this story
and he,
he immediately hits on the fact that
it's crazy that these kids came up to
you and apologize and I'm like,
I didn't even think about how insane
that is because I'm still mad,
but I'm thinking I'm talking to these
kids,
like I'm talking to disease and just
like that is kind of crazy because it's
so easy to buy into the shit that
everyone's a fucking soft motherfucker.
And then I think about it some more and
that I think about like all the gigs
I've done college wise before,
like in the past year I've been lucky to
know I did like Texas.
I did a school in Alaska,
a school in Ohio to school in Maryland
and I said much more offensive shit like
anti trump shit in the fucking red list
of states and it's all been fine,
you know,
like I've never been kicked off stage
before.
And so to me,
like this Columbia incident,
even the students there seemed like the
exception rather than the rule you'll
have,
like everyone's a soft person,
you know what I mean?
Does that make sense?
It does make sense,
but what I think is is young kids in
particular that are in a position of
power,
right?
They're running something.
They have this idea of how people should
behave that they want in their head,
and when you don't fit that mold,
then they just decided to be outraged.
Yeah.
That's what happened here.
You look at the context of what you
said.
First of all,
you're a comedian,
right?
You're obviously a guy would jokes about
shit.
Right?
So that's not a.
you're not saying anything negative
about black people or gay people.
You're essentially admitting that it's a
hardship.
I mean,
we all agreed that black people
experience racism and gay people
experience homophobia.
Everybody agrees that.
Yeah.
So that makes perfect sense and it's
funny.
Thank you man.
It's,
it's,
it's stupid.
What they're doing is stupid.
It's like,
but that's normal,
man.
Dude,
that's been going on forever.
I stopped doing colleges a long time
ago,
like the early two thousands.
I did a college in Florida and I
remember thinking these,
they don't know enough,
like this is not fun.
The only reason why I would do this for
money,
because college is paid a lot of money,
but they don't know enough there.
I mean they should if they,
if they're 18 year old kids and then get
into a club that has an 18 year old,
a limit where you can get in at 18,
they should do that and then there'll be
with other 30 olds and
people with life experience.
I don't want to.
I don't want to perform at the whim of
children and that's what these are.
These are children who are engaging in
recreational outrage.
They're deciding to be outraged.
Yeah,
that's it.
You know,
it felt like with,
with them particularly,
it felt like,
like I grew up fine.
I grew,
I didn't grow up rich,
but my parents had some money for a bit
before things went north or average
middle class people.
But like to me it's like I've been
through some life and so I know when
people who haven't been through life get
upset about shit,
it's always like the thing with Texas
and Ohio and Alaska is like,
these are like the kids of blue collar
people,
the people who have been through some
shit and maybe not even just blue
collar,
but people who have been through some
kind of life where life experience,
where they know that things aren't just
like words can hurt,
but for the most part they're fine.
It's like when like your fucking dad
loses his job.
Well,
it's also,
it's the intent of what you're trying to
do.
Yeah.
Like what are you trying to do?
You're trying to get laughs.
You're telling jokes and trying to get
laughs.
That's what you're hired to do.
Yeah.
They take the context of people forget
that comedian is a job that like I'm
here.
Like it's not who I am as a human being
necessarily.
I'm,
I will over funny first.
Oh yeah.
Funny over everything.
Oh,
well you're a fucking New York City
comedian.
You have to write.
It's just the only way it works.
It's so,
it's so crazy what people,
I think,
I don't know if kids have changed or
whatever.
No,
no,
they haven't changed.
They just think that this is the thing
to do.
Now.
Look,
when I was in,
when I was doing college is way back in
the day.
I was in my twenties.
I did a college in Connecticut and right
after I did their college I,
I was talking to the kids.
I would do,
I would do my set and then uh,
I would like open up for q and a.
yeah,
fuck's going on my throat.
But it was um,
I was probably 24,
25,
maybe,
maybe 25 at the oldest.
So I was just a couple of years older
than them.
And so it was fun for me to talk to them
about what life is like when you
actually have to pay your own bills and
you're out,
you're out free in.
Some guy goes,
uh,
you know,
you got like,
I was doing the question thing and some
guy goes,
uh,
I go,
you know,
I,
I lift his hand to tell a joke.
I go tell a joke and I go to Jews,
walk into a bar,
they buy it.
It's an old fucking street joke.
Yeah.
Street joke after the show,
you know,
the show goes great.
I'd say thank you.
I really appreciate you guys coming out.
It was really a lot of fun.
Thank you.
Goodnight.
So afterwards I would always hang around
and say hi to people and there was no
picture taken back then because you have
to have an actual camera.
They had a fucking castle.
It was a long time,
long time ago.
I'm 51,
so this is a 90,
91,
92,
somewhere around that.
So this one guy comes up to me,
goes the joke he said about Jewish
people's very offensive.
I thought he was joking,
I go,
are you serious?
And he was very offensive and he's
nervous and shit and like has a hard
time looking me in the eye.
And I go,
dude,
I go,
think about what the joke says.
It's about Jewish people being really
good at business will walk into a bar
that decided to buy it.
It's such a,
it's nothing offensive about it at all.
Like you know what's crazy is like it's
like people now and maybe forever have
always heard shit and they immediately
think this means if I'm thinking
something bad about this,
that means that someone is saying
thinking bad about it.
They decided this is a taboo subject.
Even if you're not even say anything
negative about it,
like say if you do a joke about
interracial relationships,
the best kind integration where I should
just say it.
If you just do a joke about that,
there are people that are going to put
red flags up instantly and look to
misinterpret anything that you say on
purpose because they don't want.
They don't want that thought in their
head.
They don't want the thought of know
like,
this guy's looking for antisemitism and
that joke to just walk into a bar.
They buy it.
There's none there.
You could look all day long.
It's a joke about Jewish folks by and
stuff.
It just does nothing.
Positive stereotypes.
It's like a big Dick,
black guy,
Joe.
It's not negative.
There's nothing negative about it.
Nobody gets upset that you think they
have a big Dick unless they have a
little thing.
It's a lot of lead time.
It's.
It's young people that also flexing,
right?
They're free from the control of their
parents and I find them you dealing with
that more in like rich or upper middle
class families because I think they're
more hands on with their kids and more
controlling and those kids get free.
They want to exert their own freedom and
when they get free of their parents,
they want to establish that they're
different and that they have their own
mind,
their own,
and then we're part of the new
generation.
The new generation is not going to
tolerate racism.
CIS Hetero activity and they just decide
that they're going to fucking put their
foot down,
but it's a pattern that repeats itself
over and over and over again.
It's just today they have social media
and this is the difference.
The difference is they feel like they're
empowered because they get online and
other morons that are the same age as
them.
Confirm with them.
You can just confirm any belief that you
want.
Like that's another lesson I've gotten
from this is just like confirmation bias
is like the wildest shit ever you can
find.
You can be like,
there's one lady who wrote some shit.
I'm anti gay,
anti black and other areas.
I'm like in the comments,
yes,
this is clearly.
This is clearly what he was saying.
I'm like,
what that you took that from my set.
Me.
I don't think there's a solution here.
Yeah.
I've looked at this heart for a long
time now.
We need safe spaces for comedians.
There's no solution because you're
dealing with immature people in terms of
like the literally the development of
their frontal lobe.
They're not fully formed yet.
How much do you think of it is like,
I put it in my op Ed that I wrote,
but it's like I was thinking about like
how much of it now is a function of the
fact that like we immediately get
whatever we want in our hands.
You know what I mean?
Like the instant gratification.
So it was like instant kind of thought
process where there's no real thinking
that occurs.
It's more just like,
this comes into my brain.
I hear gay black,
this has to be,
this is wrong.
It's coming out for sure.
I mean if you say gay black on stage
today in a really liberal,
very progressive environment,
you get this thing you.
But you have to say something like pro
super pro gay and super pro black and
it,
it doesn't even have to be a joke like
it.
You're better off just going for that
applause.
Break,
move,
comedian.
I mean he just want rose.
People want their comedians to be their
leaders.
That's what,
that's what it feels like.
It is wild laugh know people.
When I say people,
I mean like this next group of,
uh,
of comedy,
like kids are talking about the people
that were shot because the comedians
that are going to be their leaders
aren't even gonna be funny.
They're going to fucking die to starve
to death.
You get once you get out in the real
world.
Fuck man.
If you're not funny,
you're fucked.
Yeah.
Nothing but like,
it's like,
like if I went up there and I said
Asians other shit and fuck Whitey,
this,
I would've,
I would've been.
I would've been out on the fucking
chairs.
They were there and carried me out like
this mother fucker.
You know what I mean?
But like,
that's the thing I think like people
want,
like,
I'm not a hero man.
I'm just trying to be heard.
You know what?
Your comic.
Yeah.
I'm trying to be funny.
Yes.
That's all it is.
This is uh,
I,
I really believed that this is just a
symptom of growing up and you're just
giving these people the power to express
themselves where there's,
there's no mature,
wiser person that's around them.
It says,
hold on,
let's look at the context of what he's
doing,
examined what he's doing,
and then you're going to apologize to
him because this is clearly a fucking
joke.
You hired a guy to tell jokes.
He tells jokes and you say,
not that show.
This specific thing is strange because
they're were like,
everyone's like,
he did not respect what the event was.
Unlike like what?
I mean.
I'm not this.
I'm not your mascot here right now.
I'm.
I'm just not a pep rally dog.
I'm here to tell jokes when you weren't
hired to do a speech about this event.
I'm here to direct my fucking act.
I don't think they understand how long
it takes to write an act.
That's the.
That's another conversation though.
Comedy is fucking hard work.
I'm going to just go up there and just,
you know,
we're all out.
Last night I've ranted to you.
You were at the Improv as well,
right?
Yeah.
I.
We're grinding fucking shit up there.
Try a new beds.
It's tough and recording things.
Listening to them,
we're like,
oh,
this didn't work,
but now I got to restructure.
Now.
Now I'm going to go back and try to
figure out how I can make this gay black
joke.
Obviously gay,
but now everybody knows.
Everyone knows who you are.
Now going to go to the gay black,
gay,
black people are going to start cheering
for it.
Black Gay,
gay,
black friend.
My friend started a Hashtag challenge,
which I hope no one picks up as the
nemos challenge where if I'm on stage
somewhere,
you just come on stage and rip the mic
on.
You just fucked up.
Don't do that.
Please.
You shouldn't have said that on this.
Good luck.
Luck in the next six months.
I really don't think this is a big deal.
I just think this is is.
There's a reason why all these different
comedians had been saying.
John Malaney said this recently and I
really love John Malaney,
but I completely disagree with them.
He said,
the reason why Comedians don't do
colleges,
it's nothing to do with political
correctness has to do with the money.
That is not true.
No,
he says that because his act is really
good and really clean.
Essentially do his act anywhere.
It's an excellent act,
I mean,
and,
but there's other guys like that,
like Brian Regan,
he's got an excellent act.
He could do colleges anywhere and yeah,
like any,
anywhere they see the reason why they
don't do colleges because the kids are
too fucking sensitive.
That's 100 percent the reason.
Do you think that they don't make money
at colleges?
You don't understand how much colleges
pay?
They pay a lot of money.
It's not to a lot of.
I think to a lot of comics,
it's just not worth the hassle.
It's not worth,
you know,
like if,
if I didn't need the cash and I was like
a jerry,
you know,
if I was whatever,
like the two and a half weeks that have
spent like reading the news and getting
back and live answering emails and
getting back into the shit of just like
they said,
what if I didn't?
I would easily give that up.
But here's the flip side.
This is probably one of the best things
that ever happened to you as a stand up.
Oh yeah.
That's what I was saying.
Gigantic national attention as the,
the,
the two things every comic has said it
was one of the,
do you get paid and do is good press
right?
You're fucking pricks.
But it's true.
It's good to feel the same way after
time is sort of the wounds over.
Oh yeah.
Right now it's still raw and fresh and
you're still angry.
I'm still getting shit from comics.
Like that's my,
that's been my whole.
That's been my favorite thing about all
this is just comedians like talking shit
about like,
uh,
more than my friends post on facebook,
is uh,
I mean,
who among us hasn't wanted snatched the
mic out of knee meshes hand pieces of
shit.
Like,
let me live man.
Oh,
of course.
Of course.
The bomb hood around the world is my
comic friends that come to the fuck.
You guys do.
Jeff Ross who set this up.
Jeff.
Jeff is the one who connected us,
but yeah,
shout out.
Shout out to Jeff Ross.
Jeff said something that I agree with so
wholeheartedly.
He said,
I'm almost a comedian before I'm an
American.
And he said that on this,
right?
Yeah.
And I'm like,
yeah,
yeah.
It's like,
it's,
it's a rare person.
There's only two.
How many of us are there in the whole
country?
Is there even a thousand?
Like real,
legitimate working ones?
I don't know,
man.
How many headliners is there?
500.
Zero.
Like legit five.
How many would you pay to see?
Is it a hundred,
100 dudes in the country?
Maybe in the world?
Let me be honest.
I might pay to see two dudes outside of
the country internationally.
Fine.
Lovely people.
Good luck with that.
This shit's America.
It's,
it's,
I guess,
uh,
I mean,
I agree with Jeff wholeheartedly.
I guess like,
we're,
it's also like what he said about,
uh,
the incident,
you see a comment from a,
even if they're like in England or South
Africa and you see it,
you,
you immediately have that kinship.
You're like,
yes,
you're a comedian.
It's like you ever watch a community in
when,
when Chris and uh,
uh,
Jerry do,
I've never watched it.
Oh,
it's great.
I mean,
I just liked,
I liked,
I liked some of the interviews that he
does,
but Chris and Jerry have a moment where
they're talking about going to a party
and seeing each other and Chris comes up
to Jerry and just goes comedian,
but the only two people that know each
other and it's like,
that's the kinship that I think you have
as a,
as a comic,
but I forget what we talked about.
How do we get on this?
Well,
we were just talking about guys giving
you shit.
Oh yeah.
I mean that's,
that's the,
that's the best part is just like
motherfuckers being like you bomb and
mother.
Yeah,
I love it.
I love New York.
New York is special in that way.
With New York's extra mean because it's
cold.
Oh,
it's fucking brutal.
That's what it is.
Like la out here,
people are,
first of all,
they're trying to get acting gigs,
so the kissing ass and they're being
fake and then on top of that it's warm
all the time.
Did you start in.
What'd you start?
I started in Boston,
Boston,
New York,
La,
but I've been to la.
I've been,
I mean if you want it to look at it on
paper,
although I always considered myself a
Boston comic.
Yeah.
I'm more of an La comic than anything.
I've been out here since 94.
Oh Shit.
I was thinking about the other day.
You're a 30 year guy.
Yeah,
30 years.
That's a long time and it's your life
your whole life as a human.
You said you were on stage at college in
1990.
I was for crazy.
I think it was 92 now that I'm thinking
[inaudible] 99.
Somewhere around nine to.
But either way it's a long ass time and
the crazy thing is do you still keep
learning?
Yeah,
like you still keep learning.
Like I'll still have a weird set and I
go,
oh,
why did I do it that way?
Well,
I have this idea in my head.
Let me flip this around and it'll fuck
the whole joke up.
Like,
why did I say rescue first?
I should have said that later.
God Damn it.
That goes back to how much work this
shit is that you forget how much time
you've got to invest.
I got two new babies right now,
not not real babies and real kids,
but I have two new comedy babies even
better and I'm watering them.
Like right now.
They're like,
Ooh,
I've got to give them some light.
I got to make sure they get the right
fertilizer.
Like right now I have two bits.
One bit.
That's one day out.
I did it yesterday for the first time
I'd been working on it for a couple of
weeks.
I knew there was some life to it and I
sat down.
I wrote it out and I said,
okay,
one want a free ball.
This shit last night.
What's her process?
I have over the last three or four
years,
four years since I'm actually five.
Since I did my comedy central special in
2014.
I decided to change my process right
before that because I decided that I
needed to do more specials because I
went from.
I did one in 2009 that I really liked
that I did one in 2012 that I have asked
and then I said,
okay,
because I wasn't doing.
I wasn't at the store anymore and I
wasn't doing weekly sets,
so then I realized,
okay,
there's a.
there's a very distinct process in terms
of the work that you have to do.
First of all,
you have to go up a lot,
like you have to go up at least three or
four times a week,
excuse me,
three or four days a week and I would
like to go multiple times a night and I
like to go to different environments,
not just the store or they like to do
the Improv.
I like to do the Ice House,
I like to do different environments.
Then I have to write,
write,
like sit in front of a computer and
write and I like to do it high and I
like to do it sober.
I could to do it both ways.
Got It.
And George Carlin had an interesting
method that I think I'm starting to
adopt because I've been doing it a lot
lately,
even though it's subconscious where I
write out concepts sober and then I fire
up,
then our spark up a joint and then I go
over it again when I'm high,
like the structure's already there and
then I'll start putting the funny.
Then after the writing part,
there's a lot of going over it and
thinking about it.
I try to give it a little life before
bringing it to the stage.
Then when I bring to the stage,
I write it out on paper.
I have to write it out on paper because
that's how remember where my bullet
points are.
Then recording always and then review of
the recording.
Then rewriting after the review,
the recording,
this process is like this is my process.
When I do it that way I feel better.
I feel excited.
Like last night I came home,
I wrote till 2:30
in the morning.
I came home at 1230.
I wrote for two hours and by the time
I'm like falling asleep in front of my
laptop.
I shut the laptop,
I know I'm done,
but I feel good.
Yeah,
I'm getting it in.
I know it's happening.
Like this is all live shit working out.
Yeah,
and I go to bed.
I feel good.
I go to bed.
I'm like,
yes.
this is a live.
This bitch is alive when they wake up
and it's the first thing you think about
like,
oh yeah,
I got this.
I got this new beer that night and did
it for the first time last night and it
did well at the comedy store,
but then it crushed at the Improv and
Ooh,
this motherfucker's alive.
But what was the bit.
The bit is about old people getting stds
and nursing homes.
Fuck yes.
That is a phenomena.
It's a new thing.
This new thing that's happening.
Exactly.
Blow your Dick around if you're 85 years
old.
Exactly.
No one needs condom doing.
So,
um,
but then there's this other bit of that
I'm working on as well that's a little
bit older about dude from
the missionary that got shot up by the
arrows.
But the uncontacted tribes,
of course my people did that came from
Africa and stepping in India and
Ireland,
but they immigrated from Africa 60,000
years ago under contact at trump.
But the point being that the process for
me,
it's the most important thing.
I think all this stuff with.
It's really about.
It's about focus and attention,
focus and attention.
Thinking about that,
but the work in terms of breaking it
down,
there's a.
there's a bunch of things that I think
comedians don't do that they really
should do and the number one thing is
writing actual writing,
writing like sitting in front of a
computer or a notebook and writing.
Most comedians like to just have a bit
and they work it out on stage and they
know how it worked and then they improve
it the next set,
and especially if you're doing like the
New York City trip,
were you doing like the seller and then
you do stand that you do an all these
different sets all around town and
you're doing little short 10 minute sets
here and they're like,
it's easy to just kind of keep working
on it.
Just keep working on it,
but I think that it's critical to
actually sit alone with the material and
just look at it,
look at it and try to go,
how can I make this quicker or what's a
sneak your way to do this or what else
is in this that I'm missing?
And I think the for me,
like I,
I right now,
like I just started doing up until
probably like a year ago,
maybe eight months ago,
I was of the brain where I was like,
I'll write a note or write a bullet,
bullet,
bullet point or whatever and I'll try
and work it out and then I'll write
something that I think is interesting as
a joke,
but like I saw no opening for disease or
working with a song like working with
people that are like crushing it.
Their process is like fuck they're
maniacs when the like you were just
like,
yes,
I have a codified process.
This is exactly.
I'm going to do it.
This is what's worked for like 10,
15 years,
however long I've been doing it.
And once I saw like that process,
I'm like,
oh these motherfuckers,
I think I work hard,
but these guys work fucking crazy hard
and it's like sort of emulate that
process of like I got to set aside at
least 20,
30 minutes a day where I'm like
literally,
right.
Even if it's the same thing over and
over,
I was just like,
okay,
how can I fix this,
this word doesn't need to be there.
Like,
and then I'll say it in my apartment to
myself and I'll try to do like how I
would do it on stage because it's like
I'm my comedy,
I tried to be conversational,
at least make it seem conversational.
So it's like,
how can I seem relaxed while doing this?
But still emphasize the right word for
that's the punchline or whatever it is.
Yeah.
And now that process like,
and it's all repetition now when you got
to repeat the process to make it a
profit.
Otherwise this is the thing you did
once.
And so now that's,
that's what I'm starting to do now.
Just physically fucking getting up and
be like,
okay,
this I gotta write this bid out.
Even though it was a bit.
I've done a billion times but something
in there that I got to figure out.
Yeah.
Um,
another thing to do that really works
well to sort of get it in your head is a
cork board to have a big old bullets and
board and put index cards on none of the
titles of your bits.
And then I would put like index cards
underneath it that are like the bullet
points of that bit.
Kind of like a storyboard or maybe kind
of step back and look at them and then
try to see if they make sense in order.
Like maybe I should flip it around.
Maybe I should do the bit about the guy
getting bit by the dog before I do the
bit about the monkey,
the difference between being bit by a
monkey and like maybe it's better to
introduce this distrust of animals
because in this way or you know,
who knows?
It's about attention though.
That's the thing.
It's attention and focus.
And these guys.
Have you seen that work really hard?
It's not a coincidence that those guys
are killing it.
I mean,
there's something to it and there's also
the recognition when you do start
killing it,
like,
oh shit,
this is rare.
Like I'm in a rare spot.
I'm filling up these gigantic places.
People coming out to see me.
I'm doing netflix specials.
You got to work harder now.
Yeah,
you gotta keep it up and you gotta keep
it up and you got to realize that you
are like,
Bill Burr said something once that I
think was really,
really,
really like dead on the money.
He said,
I know what it's like to be disappointed
by someone that you go to see,
like you go to see a band.
He goes,
I remember going when I see a band when
I was a kid and they half asset and you
know,
like you feel fucked over.
He goes,
I don't ever want to do that to my fans.
I was like,
ah Ha.
Yeah.
That's it.
Like realize that you used to be a fan
and I'll think of your fans as like
what?
How you would experience you.
They don't want someone phoning it in,
you know,
that's their night,
right?
That is their night it came out to see
someone they love and it's like,
you got to fucking earn that love
almost.
Yeah.
And tickets are expensive and they had
to work to get those tickets and a lot
of people doing jobs they fucking hate.
And,
and cutting back on other things to have
enough money to go out and have a few
drinks.
Yeah.
It's uh,
there's,
there's a responsibility to it,
but there's also a lot of people that
try to skirt that responsibility because
of the pressure of that responsibility
is kind of overwhelming.
You think about it,
it makes you nervous and you just start,
you fuck off and you have ass and I'll
be fine.
Yeah.
But that's like college,
right?
It's like cramming for tests.
It's like there's a lot of people that
study all year long and there's a lot of
people that half acid up until the last
minute and then they just try to shove
it all in all at once.
It's a weird kind of confidence that you
need or or delusional delusional
delusional competence where like,
I'll be fine fucking.
And I admit I've done that a few times
where I've just been like,
fuck it,
I'll,
I'll work this out.
It'll be straight.
But like the Times where I've like
fucking sat and been like,
this is the bit I gotta do I gotTa make
sure I hit it to the point where I'll
just bring the notebook on stage and
just be like,
okay,
I gotta make sure this,
this goes away.
I wanted to go,
these are the old expression,
how you do anything is how you do
everything or how you do everything is
how you do anything.
And that's,
there's something to that too.
There's something to like not allowing
yourself to think of yourself as someone
who's a fuckup yeah.
Because as soon as you think of,
I'm just a fuck up.
If you get that in your head man.
And that like the default setting almost
where it's like that's easy to do with
human are like,
I think people are hardwired to work,
but it's also very easy to just not do
that and I believe that it'll be fine or
or five,
fuck this up.
Like the pressure alleviator as you put
these expectations on yourself of
success in the end,
there's a lot of pressure involved in
meeting those expectations and one of
the best pressure relievers is just
fucking up.
So you lower your own personal
expectations.
People drinking,
doing all that kind of shit.
Just like sabotaging your life.
There's a lot of people that will
sabotage their life.
They start getting some success and then
the panic overwhelms them and they'll
just start taking pills or go,
go fucking crazy.
I'm gonna,
lose this.
I'm going to fuck it up.
Anyway.
Yeah,
I know.
That mentality is really normal.
Yeah.
The psychological mind fuck that goes on
when you're attempting to do anything,
whether it's standup comedy or I guess
it would probably be the same with
almost any art form.
You're especially open-ended art forum
where you don't have a boss who's
telling you,
hey,
you know,
mess,
you got to get this fucking project in
at 3:00
if that's the.
That's the crazy thing is like you
forget.
Or like what people don't know is that
comedy is the most entrepreneurial
endeavor.
There is you fucking there and that's
why everyone thinks they could do it
because there's no capital investment of
fuck it.
It's all just mental investment in hard
work and everybody thinks they can do it
because they do most of it.
See,
most of it is just talking.
Yeah.
So like I could talk,
I could talk.
How come I can't talk like I've made
people have to do it and funny at the
office,
Dude,
I'm funny all the time I'm going to do
standup.
Like how many people have you heard say,
I think I'm thinking about doing stand
up and you're like,
oh God.
I'm like,
good luck man.
You know?
Because some people I'm like,
I know they have the work ethic to do
whatever the fuck that.
If like if my friends were super
successful in most other endeavors like
that,
they do like finance or doctors or
whatever applied the same work ethic to
comedy.
They might be successful if they're
funny,
but a lot of people think they're funny
and then just forget that fucking the
work part.
Whereas a like,
Yo,
fuck,
this is slave shit.
Ain't no one and there's no one whipping
you.
The only one,
no one but yourself.
It's just you'll get the fucking work
done.
It's also you're the writer,
the producer,
and you're the actor.
You're the person who does the whole
thing.
The marketing expert.
You got to all the above.
Yeah.
It's all fucking you.
It's a weird gig and you have to be a
self starter because if you're not the
type of person that knows how to
motivate yourself and get out of bed and
get things done,
you'll just fucking lay around until
three in the afternoon.
Then you go eat a sub and have a cup of
coffee and then the man my sets in two
hours,
I think I'm gonna be taking a nap.
You feel like you did something because
you wrote some shit in your mole skin
foot right before you went up doing a
lot of writing lately.
One mole skin,
three years,
fucking 10,
10 words on it.
It's,
it's,
uh,
there's no,
there's no fucking structure to it
either in terms of like there's
education that you can
get other than self education you can't
go to.
If you want to learn how to play the
cello,
you could take lessons.
Someone will teach you how.
I mean there's a real clear process
between,
you know,
being a symphony violinist know,
like going to school,
getting an education in music,
becoming a symphony violinists.
Just auditioning Asian.
Yeah.
That helps a lot.
That is the fence.
Get off the stage.
He said something about an ethnicity.
It must be bad.
I mean,
there's no real clear process to
becoming a standup comedian.
It just.
Everybody's like,
what do you do?
You go to an open mic,
figure it out.
You're on your own.
Everybody just wants you to get it.
Tell me how you go from doing comedy to
becoming a writer for snl.
Is there a shortcut,
like what's.
Oh yeah,
call this number and say,
Abracadabra,
this is Lauren's number.
Yeah.
You tell it.
You tell them one joke and if he laughs
you hired.
Is that then you're in?
Yeah.
There's no.
There's no way to teach someone how to
be a comic either.
That's the other thing,
like the way you do jokes is different
than the way he jamie would do jokes or
different than the way you know fucking
Judas freelander would do jokes.
Everybody's different and there's no
one.
No one is right.
Like if you went over to Judah
freelander xact and went Nema and you're
doing this shit all wrong.
You gotta he's gotTa have actual
punchlines,
right?
You're just saying a bunch of shit.
That's not true.
You've got to stop this.
It's very fucking good,
man.
He's hilarious.
But his act is uniquely him.
Kick it.
Never teach anybody how to do that.
No.
Like that act.
He had a figure that act out on his own
and he's developed a so well.
Yeah,
I mean that's the thing.
Yeah.
I think like with comedy,
the heart,
the crazy shit is,
is that everyone thinks they could do in
the sense that like,
oh,
I could tell a joke and I could show.
A lot of people can tell a joke.
My mom could tell a joke my that
everyone can tell a joke because it's
written in Shit,
but it's so hard to cultivate who you
are because that's you're also doing
that.
You're like trying to figure out,
okay,
I've got a bunch of fucking insane shit
and my brain and this is how I think it.
I got to figure out how I'm going to say
it.
That's not necessarily how everyone else
would say it,
but it's just how I feel about it and
I'm going to say it that way.
Take into account the economy of words.
You want to sneak it up on people.
You want to get the idea into their head
before they figured it out on their own,
so like boom,
like it pops.
I'm like,
you gotta you want.
It's like a little race,
like the.
You have to figure out a way to
introduce it in a way that's unique and
captivating and entertaining,
but also quick enough to get into their
brain before they figured out where
you're going.
Because the worst thing is when you see
guy on stage and you're like,
oh,
I know where this is going,
and then he gets there and then a few
people go,
ha ha,
ha ha.
What took so long?
I was there yesterday dog I saw coming
from the moment you.
Unless they can say
it and you see it coming and it still
hits you because it's so good.
It's so stupid.
That's just really good writing and the
good delivery in a good idea,
you know,
but it's also on the other hand,
I mean we're talking about how hard it
is.
It's also the most fun shit of all time
when it works.
Oh yeah,
pops off when you had to have a new bit
and you have that pause right before you
deliver and you like.
And I told him that's not real.
And then ever goes,
oh,
I got to hear the beginning of this.
You know what?
I mean,
it's like you hit these punchlines and
the whole audience laughs and roars and
they're having a good time and it's one
of the greatest feelings in life.
It's because,
because you,
you know,
but you don't know until it comes out of
your mouth and then you're like,
oh,
well,
it's also,
you're making people feel good.
Like there's something about looking
out.
You know,
you go to the Improv last night,
190 people in that room and you're
looking out into the audience at all.
These people are having a great time
laughing and having so much fun.
I got all your numbers.
You know what I mean?
Got Feeling.
I know what.
You know why you're laughing at this.
I know why you're not laughing at
something.
I know who you are.
A little aspect of who you are because
you're laughing at this bit and what
you've been through and you're giving
them a good feeling.
You've given them a good thing.
It's a good exchange.
Like they came to see you like they sat
down.
They're less willing to let you talk in
front of a microphone raised above them
on a stage.
Right?
This is a very unique arrangement in
human beings that this person like,
please welcome Jamie Vernon.
He goes up on the stage,
gets up the hey everybody and the like.
This is it.
It's an exchange.
It's a unique contract where you're
like,
okay,
I'm going to give this person who has a
microphone 10 minutes of my time,
my precious time,
and in that 10 minutes you've got to
make me feel better about my life that
has nothing or escape my life,
or whatever it is.
People say,
well,
you're making them feel like when I go
to see a comic and they they kill.
Let's say David tells goes onstage and
he's killing.
I'm feeling better because of his
laughs,
because of his jokes.
When he's.
He's cracking jokes about things.
I'm like,
I got feel good.
It gets in your body like he's giving
you a little drug.
Were drug dealers.
Look,
if you could get a drug,
if you could go to the 7:11
and it was an over the counter thing
while you saying 7:11
convenience store,
that is time.
That could have been a big phone pa.
I'm offended.
Okay.
Store 24.
I'll go back to Boston.
But if you could buy something over the
counter and it was a laughter drug,
we could just take a pill and everything
would be hilarious and funny.
God,
everybody would take that.
So greatest feeling ever.
You.
You laugh at something and you think
it's a really funny and not that happens
to you.
There's no negative side effects to
enhance your girl might be mad at you if
you have it.
Something as opposed to what are you
going to do?
Yeah.
That's funny.
When you see girls getting upset at guys
laughing my face because you could like,
like even last night you could,
you could see their couples and you
tell.
I told a joke and I could see what girl
is looking at.
What guy versus what guys just like
laughing it up.
I have a fiance now,
but we got engaged like three or four
weeks ago and I do this bit about or
where I'm just like,
I'm a one night she got mad at me
because I closed the door too loud
because she was sleeping and I was drunk
and I came home.
I just accidentally closed the door and
I was like,
that's how you like the bit is I say,
you know,
there's two ways to close the door.
As Amanda's a regulator,
just close it like you've been taught
your whole life.
And then there's another way.
If you live with your girlfriend,
you come home like she's sleeping,
you gotta turn the Doorknob,
push it into the frame and then release
it so it doesn't make a noise or a
relationship.
My end and you see guys and girls going,
who told you that's how you got to do.
I'm just like,
that to me is like the best where it's
like I know everything that these
motherfuckers are going through in this
fucking moment and the and like they're
gonna go home and talk about.
See,
I told you that the doors shit was too
loud.
That's the fucking.
That's my favorite part of doing any bit
where it's like you could see a couple
of just react to some shit.
Well,
I feel sorry for people that don't have
a job where they can be creative.
I really do.
I think whatever you're doing,
whatever it is,
if you're a person who enjoys creating
things,
it's one of the most rewarding feelings
of building something that wasn't there
before and then all of a sudden it's
there and you made it.
It's like there's,
it's very hard like completing a,
an act like if you have,
you started set.
Have you recorded anything yet?
Like a special.
No,
no,
no.
I,
I did a spot on seth meyers in like July
of last year,
my first arms.
Oh,
okay.
On TV.
How was,
that was a weird.
No,
I mean it seems like a nice guy as a
man.
I love seth.
I mean I,
I met him before because at updates,
so he came upstairs and like hang out.
Would it come hang out with us?
Um,
the show itself was great.
You know,
the process with,
with uh,
the booker there,
it was very simple because they're like
big fans of comedy,
like seth is obviously a fan of comedy,
but the lady that books a show is also a
big fan of comedy.
So I was a bit nervous just because it
was like my first time going on in front
of millions of people,
whatever.
People watched that.
Then I was just like,
I got to make sure that my writing and
my jokes come off as fucking strong as
possible and it went great.
You know,
there's obviously some people trolls
like talking shit on Youtube,
but for the most part everyone's like,
man,
it's fucking,
it's so tough not to.
It's so tough.
Smart.
With the thing that you're doing with
the instagram where you deleted every
day and then I can download.
I got it.
I got to check,
like if anyone's hit me up for a Gig or
some shit,
but otherwise
I'm just like,
I fucking hate all men.
That's what I do.
I just don't.
I mean you just develop habits,
you know,
like,
but the problem is it's an itchy thing.
Like you start,
you get itchy.
It was check real quick.
Just take those times and just go over
your notes.
When you get itchy and you want to look
at your phone.
Like who?
Who said this?
Someone said it.
Someone said it really recently.
Oh God,
I don't want to.
I want to fuck it up.
Somebody said this in a tweet.
A wanna say it was Ted Alexandro.
No,
mark normand was mark Norman.
He,
he,
he went up after I did A.
I did this.
I did a talk about Columbia at one night
at the cellar and he went up after me.
Immediately goes,
I don't know why the right knee mashed
up now.
He's been bombing for years.
He's a shit.
They crushed level.
The normans funny,
but he's a man.
But he,
uh,
he did a joke about how checking twitter
is like opening up an empty refrigerator
and hoping that there's something new in
there and they never asked.
He just go,
fuck it.
Let me check it again.
There's nothing in there.
It's like that same feeling.
I botched his joke.
Ruined it,
but I got it.
But that's,
yeah,
that is really what it is.
It's this weird compulsion,
this instantaneous gratification thing
that you're getting off of some weird
dopamine hit by,
by touching that device and getting
information to pop up.
But it's not satisfying.
There's nothing there.
Nothing that you've ever been on a
safari,
a safari in Africa.
You mean you got to go.
I went in April,
I spent all my money is gone on
engagement.
Bringing fucking as,
as supplies is expensive and I don't
mean to sound.
Were you in one of those open air jeep?
It's like,
that's when up until like April I went
in April.
I was just like,
like addicted to my phone but like using
it too much,
more or less.
But in Botswana where we went,
obviously there's no server,
say anything.
I'm just like fuck this shit.
And like the week even though just a
week of not being on this thing,
I was just like,
I feel so much better.
You are,
you,
you can think.
Yeah.
And like the whole time you're in an
open air car and just like out,
like when was the last time you drove
for like an hour and there was nothing
but like noise or like animals and shit.
You know what I mean?
There's nothing but this like you the
air and just like hanging out.
Just thinking shit.
Yeah.
I hunt in every year.
I do three or four trips were like for a
week basically lost in the woods.
Disconnected.
It's the best.
It's the fucking.
It's what's interesting.
Even in the hunting world,
a lot of people like instagramming while
they're hunting and they're doing
instastories while they're out there in
the forest.
It's good when there's no connection
when there's no service and no
connection,
it's good.
You can just leave this shit away.
I broke my phone when I was in Hawaii
and I was there a Ozon Lanai,
which is a kind of a remote island.
It's hard to get things there.
And so I,
I just kept dropping my iphone.
I dropped,
dropped that shit like 10 times and I
dropped it and it just started making
phone calls.
I got,
hold it up,
it would just open up my context.
I will watch this and I was showing my
wife,
it just starts calling people like and I
hang up and starts calling another
person,
calling another person.
Hang on.
I just broke it.
It was just Jack.
And so I uh,
I had to order a new one and then it got
to a point where wouldn't let me input
my code and it wouldn't recognize my
face.
It was like,
it was dead.
it was just fried.
It took three days to get one.
So for three days I had no phone and it
was crazy.
It was crazy.
I felt better,
I felt better.
I was walking around,
but then I was like,
well,
I can't wait to get my phone.
Why I feel good without it.
Everyone knew around people you love the
people you need to reach.
Like it's like,
yeah,
what?
You're not missing anything from Google.
Not Missing anything,
but you feel like you are.
Check twitter,
instagram,
instagram is,
we're addicted to it to a point where
it's like,
it feels like cigarettes in the fifties
where it's like no one.
Here it is mark dorm and social media is
like,
look in the fridge over and over,
you know,
there's nothing good,
but you check it so many times that
eventually you start consuming things
you don't even like.
Yeah.
Even better.
There we go.
Start bleeding.
Tweet leftover 2,630
likes son is going to go up a lot now.
Yeah,
probably.
But um,
yeah,
it's uh,
it's in my real fear is that this is one
stage of a complete connection to
electronics and to each other that's
unhealthy and unproductive and
unavoidable because I don't think we're
gonna end with social media,
like twitter and instagram where it's
like you can just press a button,
get it.
It's going to be completely connected to
your brain.
Yeah.
We're going to have that fairly soon.
I've,
I feel like within the next 10 years
that's going to be a normal thing that
you can just pull up information
instantaneously.
It's almost like the phone,
the watch thing feels almost like
wearing a digital watch.
No,
this is a regular watch,
isn't my dad's Rato from like 1980
something.
They make such cool digital watches now.
A lot of them look like that.
Look cool now.
Yeah,
but that's.
I think the next step is like,
oh,
I can just do this.
I don't even got to.
What's the prompt you.
It's like you can't reach in your pocket
to check your shit.
Just got an iphone,
watch whatever the fuck they call that
thing.
I watch and I wore it twice.
I was like,
what am I doing with this thing?
I don't even like.
It buzzes.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
This person texted me.
You still got to fucking go on this
thing to say,
yeah,
I'm not this enough.
Phone is enough.
I mean,
the only thing that's good for is your
heart rate.
It monitors your heart rate when you
run.
It's good for that.
It's called the race thing.
Watching it.
It also logs the amount of time and
miles that you put in and your.
Your heart rate variability and all that
stuff.
This is some good aspects to it in terms
of a fitness tracker,
but other than that it's like,
to what end,
what are you doing?
What's going on?
But I don't run.
So for me,
when Elan was on the podcast,
he was talking to me about his neuro
link thing that he's going to be coming
out with.
He said back then,
and this was,
what was that three months ago?
Somewhere around three months ago.
He said that they were going to be
coming out with it within four to six
months.
So that's any day now.
So I don't know what the fuck this is,
but he said essentially it's gonna.
It's gonna open up the bandwidth between
you and information that's going to
radically change the way human beings
information.
Uh,
it,
the way human beings access information.
It's like a internet thing.
Wouldn't tell me why.
That's all he would tell blink neurolink
yeah,
because it's on,
you know,
we were on air when he was saying it,
but I oddly trust him to be a
phenomenal,
a net positive for the universe.
Oh,
100 percent.
You know,
it was like Zuckerberg and like other
times net doesn't net negative for like
they are the reasons.
They are a lot of the reasons why
society has gone the way it has because
you can confirm whatever the fuck.
But Elan,
I'm like,
yeah man,
why not fucking build a car that you
don't need any gasoline for?
Why not fucking send shit to this space?
Yeah.
I think he's a net positive for us.
I am 100 percent convinced he's a net
positive.
I think he's a legitimate genius and I
don't think there's a lot of them.
Yeah,
I think Mark Zuckerberg is a smart guy.
He was very ambitious.
I think there's a big difference.
Yeah,
and Zuckerberg quote that I read
recently that what's good for the world
is not necessarily good for facebook.
I'm like,
that's it.
Shut it down.
He said that he burned it to the ground.
That's all out.
Pull out,
pull out.
He's let the fuck.
Did you just say,
well,
how much money do you have?
Jesus,
first of all,
don't you have like $18,000,000,000?
How much more do you need?
Bitch,
you sitting over here talking about
what's good for facebook is not
necessarily good for the good.
You got all the good for 18 fucking
hundred lifetimes.
Jesus Christ.
He said that,
that's exactly that.
My favorite Zuckerberg joke,
uh,
we,
we were at update and this was when
Zuckerberg is a being grilled by
Congress and when he's sipping wine to
like this and Chris rock comes by and he
goes,
uh,
you know what I didn't like about that
trial.
There's nothing worse than watching
someone being grilled by Congress when
there's no stakes.
Nothing happens to mark Zuckerberg if
even if the shit goes worse for him,
nothing happens to that guy.
Right?
That's my face.
Like I'm just like,
you never think about it that way where
nothing happens to him.
If,
if even if facebook blows up,
well,
here's what could happen.
If facebook intentionally concluded,
if there was some
sort of proof that they received some
financial compensation to lean one way
or the other.
Is that,
is that was percolating right now?
No,
but it could be.
This is what they were searching for
when they're searching for is what we're
trying to find out.
How is it that these Russian bots are
able to disseminate propaganda so
readily and so easily and so
efficiently?
What are you doing?
Stop that.
How has all this stuff propagated?
Like where's this coming from?
Yeah,
and the people that were asking were
techno ignorant and that was part of the
problem with Congress,
so it was like a Google makes the iphone
right?
Going to ask him to Google and say,
how come my niece has got bad words on
her iphone and someone has to tell them.
Google doesn't make the iphone the whole
place roars.
Like when you go to Congress to laugh,
like everybody's laughing at what a
fucking idiot you are.
These are the people that are asking the
question.
That's terrifying.
Exactly.
You need.
You need people from like ars Technica.
You need people from like,
you know,
a scene that you need people from.
You need fucking techno guys.
People,
men and women who really understand
technology should be throwing those
questions around Asians.
Yeah,
and people with autism.
You need people that really,
truly understand what the complications
are,
what,
what the ramifications are and what they
could have done to prevent these things.
I think that what happened with facebook
and what's happening with twitter and a
lot of these other things is no one
anticipated the impact culturally.
They were going to have the.
I was talking about this the other day
about a with Sam j like maybe a few
months ago about like how it's the
democratization of information and how
easy it is to pretend like you know what
you're talking about.
That's like the majority of the problem,
like facebook,
twitter,
all this shit because it used to be all.
You need an infrastructure to spread
news.
You needed a fucking truck factory.
Now you don't even need pants.
You could just fuck it.
Just got to put like a weird fucking
eagle on your website and it's like this
is the fucking news.
Now.
Don't even have to have a website that
have a popular twitter account.
That's.
There's a lot of people out there that
have popular twitter accounts and when
you go to the twitter account,
and I.
There's quite a few people that I
followed that I don't follow.
What that means is I bookmark their page
so that they don't even know that I
follow them because they're fucking
insane.
I don't want them sending me DDMS and
I'll go and read their stuff and they
are on there all day.
Yeah,
man,
all day.
They're doing battle against the good
and the bad.
The dark forces in the light,
they're just fucking going after it and
they develop these sort of a news portal
pages and you don't even know who the
fuck these people are.
You don't know anything about them but
their page or it's all battling and I
know I follow people that are like
hardcore right wing people that had just
battling the lab.
They're hilarious.
It's so silly.
And then I follow people that are hard
core lefties that are battling the
right.
Everyone's a Nazi and everyone's all
right like you're outright for it
doesn't matter if you support every
fucking single liberal principle.
There is no
the Oh the craziest shit about this.
This whole Columbia shit is that I was
featured on Breitbart.
They finally like a brown dude.
I'm like,
I cannot be like,
I got emails from people at Fox News
like,
Hey,
do you want to come on to show that
Dinesh D'souza Guy?
Right?
Yeah,
they're fucking.
I hate that guy.
I was about to say something bad guys
can't stand that motherfucker.
Well,
he's the only brown guy that made it
through him and him and fucking Bobby
Jindal like they're trying.
They're trying to turn me into this
motherfucker.
I'm like,
I'm not coming on your fucking TV shows
so you can use me as your.
So everything's gone a muck and PC.
I've wished free speech was under attack
because like,
some people need to shut the fuck up.
You know what I mean?
Like this.
There's too much shit.
Everyone has a podcast show me,
you don't deserve to speak a lot of
times.
Fucking crazy.
Tell everybody get to,
to get a podcast.
But now I stopped because,
uh,
first of all,
I don't think,
I don't think you can anymore.
I think over the last few years it's
getting so saturated that it's almost
impossible to break through.
On top of that.
It's like some people,
I don't want to.
Shit,
you don't need a everyone's opinion
about it like you.
You shouldn't have to fucking work to
develop,
to have the right to have an opinion
about some things.
Well you should.
You definitely should have a good
opinion.
It should be something.
Well thought out nuance.
There's no nuance anymore either.
It's because because everything's got to
be black and white.
Especially with a lot.
This younger generation was like,
if something's not black and white,
it goes fucking arrive for them because
they want it to be black and white,
so they'll create a false narrative
where it is black or white.
Yes.
That's the one thing that you see a lot
today where people pretend that someone
is something and they,
they,
they do this reductionist thing where
they boil it down to one thing,
you know,
he went on stage and said anti gay anti
black jokes at Columbia.
This guy's a piece of shit.
All right.
Fucking doorway.
He's a portal,
like an Indian portal to the outright.
That's who you think I am as a magic
carpet to the outright.
Hey Man,
I wish I could.
I wish I could just be offended all the
time.
You can seal very hard to hurt my
feelings.
Like your comment.
Yeah.
It's like it's just so crazy.
I find me a comic.
It's easy to hurt their feelings and
they fucking suck.
They suck.
You have to.
It's fucking but was saying is like with
this right.
Shit.
It was like everyone wants to put
somebody in and their own agenda.
This reduction is shit.
I just like,
this is how I feel about it and look at
the points that make me seem smart.
Incorrect about this.
Yeah,
and they're trying to do that online in
front of everybody instead of like this
internal examination of their actual
feelings and how they really think about
things and whether or not they make
sense or whether or not it's objective.
Instead of that they're broadcasting
this and this sort of weird way that's
at least partially intentionally
deceptive.
Like the acknowledgement that there's
some.
That there is nuance,
there is no,
life is fucking complicated and ideas
are complicated.
Especially ideas in terms of when
you're.
When you're talking about this cultural
sort of battle that's going on right now
between the you,
they're attacking people who are like
clearly very left wing,
but for not being left wing enough and
they're running out of target.
I will bother me.
Someone hit me up saying,
you haven't spoke out against the white
supremacists and people that are
harassing,
uh,
this group and these,
this blogger that's going off like Wah
Wah.
I'm like far as like,
of course I didn't do not support any
white supremacists.
Anybody fucking going after these kids
for whatever reason.
What seeds are they talking about?
The Asian American alliance,
like the Asian American lions posted
some shit on facebook and like,
all of these fucking crazy people have
apparently been like talking shit to
them.
And I'm like,
that's.
I don't subcon I condemn that action.
But second of all,
does my mere existence not testified to
the fact that I'm not,
I'm not.
Pro is my name.
Nicholas Patterson.
Fucking Nimesh Patel is the most Indian
motherfucking name I could think of.
Like like,
I'm going to call up someone at the KKK,
but hey guys,
thank you.
That is hilarious that you have not
denounced white supremacists.
So by your,
your Dave decided that you haven't acted
enough.
Sometimes there'll be a story online and
I will get a tweet with someone.
Say Your silence about this story is
deafening.
I was like,
what?
Fucking starting broad.
I didn't pay attention to half the shit.
I can't,
but I cannot.
Like someone had to tell me that that
was happening before I was like,
oh,
okay,
that's fucking whack out.
I'll respond some way.
Also,
I want to think about things before I
respond.
Yeah.
You know,
when the Louis ck thing went down,
I got a lot of angry tweets into one of
them from a fucking journalists that
I've done stories with.
I've done interviews with this guy
before and he was talking shit about
comedians that have not denounced Louis
C k.
and I'm like,
hey man,
I just like,
you don't know what really happened.
I don't know the whole story.
I know what he said and I know what she
said.
And,
uh,
the whole thing seems to me like a big
old cluster fuck even.
Okay,
let's,
let's put it this way.
Like,
like you can denounce his actions.
If he said he did all this shit that he
mess.
Ew,
that's gross.
Yeah.
I think what he did was incorrect and
wrong.
But the fact that like,
you should denounce that you should not
be working again.
I'm like,
you forget I'm also a comic and be
murderers.
Make parole dog like the fucking you
got.
Where does it end?
Almost there's,
there's some things that you should be
way more upset about.
How about a hastert the guy who's the
speaker of the house who went to jail
for fucking kids and he molested a bunch
of kids and he only got 15 months.
What?
Yeah.
That's.
I didn't even know that.
That's crazy.
Exactly that.
So meanwhile everybody is ranting and
railing about Louis C,
k.
not that this diminishes what Lucy Kay
did,
but I'm saying there's some real horrors
in the world and to choose to
concentrate on the comedian who asked
women,
can I jerk off in front of you?
They said yes,
and he did it.
He didn't hold anybody in a room against
their will or force them to watch him or
what he did was just gross and he
stopped doing it like more than 10 years
ago.
It's not good,
but the fact that someone would think
that I need to make a statement about
it,
like bitch,
I don't need to make a statement about
anything.
I don't need to talk about anything.
I don't want to talk to him about like,
who are you?
It's so quick.
We automatically,
when I say we,
I mean people at large sort of assume
the worst about a person immediately.
I think it's also this social media
thing.
Yeah.
It's,
I don't think they really assume that.
I think they just have this opportunity
to express themselves in a way that
they're going to get a reaction out of
you and this is the way to do it.
I also,
you know,
what's crazy is that like I,
we've been harping on this younger
generation,
but I've said some shit at like seller
and Vu,
like very anti trump shit and people
have been like,
when I view the sellers,
one of the other clubs,
I said,
um,
I forgot what I said about trump.
I basically fat shaming because I think
he's a fat piece of shit,
but like I said,
more articulate in joke form and some
guy got up and I was like,
fuck this,
and it just bounced.
And I'm like,
that's what you're mad about.
You not mad about the fact that he is
that,
that your president is a billionaire
that doesn't use his money to just hire
a personal trainer once in a while.
Like adderall.
Mcdonald's diet is not the way you want
your fucking president to be living in
his life more or less.
And this person just got up and bounce
them because it's heated.
And I talked to him after I was like,
what?
What do you,
what are you mad about?
So I think it's just as he say,
he was like,
I don't like the words that you were
using is very crude from Nebraska,
Florida.
Look Man,
I'm not gonna like the words you were
using it at the comedy cellar.
Vulgar on like on like dog.
Like come on man.
You're like,
that's what I'm saying.
I feel like it's fixed.
Like just have a safe space for comics
were like where there's a sign that the
seller and I was a swim at your own
risk.
You coming down like weird.
You're here to see us.
I'm not here to fucking song.
Sing a dance for you guys.
You guys are here.
This is an exchange.
This is an agreement that all you have
to do is not laugh or laugh.
Well,
it's also the people that are going down
to see that stuff that like it expect
you to do that kind of comedy.
They expect you to go hard.
Right?
That's what it's about.
If I go there and everybody's pulling
back,
all of a sudden I'm at the tonight show
and all of a sudden I'm at a Jimmy
Fallon monologue.
Like,
well,
well that's someone that came here for.
I came here to have a couple of drinks
and here's some crazy shift from greer
barnes.
You know what I mean?
This,
I want to hear some real standup.
I don't want to hear this stupid shit.
And you know,
people that can't handle some offensive
stuff that you shouldn't be at a comedy
club.
This is where people go to say offensive
stuff that's like you don't want dirt in
your hands and you're in a garden.
Like this is stupid.
What?
Like manage some expectations.
Yeah.
It was just was like,
hey,
but people politically,
man,
when you get into their,
you know their team and you're shitting
on their team,
he's probably Republican.
Of course he has brain damage.
He's living in Florida.
Water's tough.
Everything's.
To me it's like this,
like politically like people are,
are so like that's part of their
personality.
Almost were like having.
I have done a lot of political comedy,
you know,
and to me it's like when you do that,
you're almost talking to them as,
as if their politics are their person,
like,
and that's the kind of crazy thing.
Like I don't,
my politics are not necessarily who I am
as a human being.
Like I can,
I'm pretty liberal when it comes to
social issues but might be fairly
conservative when it comes to financial
issues and fiscal issues and I'm just
like,
don't take what,
who I voted for it to be who I am as a
human being.
There's no one has that nuance anymore
about anything.
Yeah,
it's an identity issue.
People find whatever team it is,
whether it's progressive or conservative
and they just decide this is my identity
and they cloak themselves in it and then
they defend it and some,
someone that someone like yourself was
saying jokes that are contrary to that.
I am talking shit about their
quarterback.
Quarterback is about to get fucking pop
to Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ every day.
It's like he's still there,
Huh?
I've
never fucking last two weeks.
I've never like,
wanted more like trump to say something
wild just so people would stop fucking
just stopped seeing emails and fucking
new Google alerts about Nimesh Patel,
whatever.
Just like,
look,
this guy's crazy,
man.
Well you shouldn't be googling your name
first of all.
Definitely shouldn't be reading that
stuff.
Deleted the Google alerts.
I deleted all that shit.
Yo.
It was crazy.
My mom,
once my,
once my mom didn't even tell my parents
that that should happen.
Uh,
what they heard my dad works at a liquor
store and someone came with a copy of
the post and be like,
on the second page is me.
It's like that's your son.
Right?
And then the post say they talking shit
about,
you know,
they were,
they were like,
can you believe these fucking kids?
Good.
And then went in here and then,
uh,
and then,
and then I was like,
it was still dead because up until that
point everyone is sort of like,
it's more just like the pushing the
narrative that everyone's kind of soft
Thursday morning,
uh,
like four days,
five days after it happened,
I got a text from Lenny Marcus at like
8:00
in the morning saying,
hey man,
you're trending on Yahoo.
I'm like,
I'm trending,
trending.
I'm number one on Yahoo News Thursday
morning.
And I'm like.
And then like that day my mom texted me
just say,
Hey,
what happened at Columbia?
I said,
I didn't get in.
That was the only thing I said.
And then she calls me and she's like
telling me like,
what did you do as your career?
Okay.
I'm like,
I'm fine.
His kids,
they didn't like the joke I said.
And like I didn't really,
I didn't tell them is it's sold that
even for them to get stand up has been
such an uphill battle for parents.
Yeah.
Just to be like,
what are you doing up until like for the
two years I was unemployed and like
living at home and go into the city
every night because I'm from Jersey,
so I'll go to the city every night to do
stand up.
They're like,
what the fuck is,
what are you doing with your life?
Right.
And so even up until then it come see me
until like seven,
seven years in.
That's good.
Yeah.
You get your legs under you?
That brought him to the seller was dope.
You know,
parents came to see me like a year in
they shit.
But you can't do that dog still doing
open mics,
man.
Joe,
we're going to fix your room up again.
Changed.
What are you doing?
Cleaning the basement out.
It's not gonna work.
But.
So when my mom saw it,
she called me and she's like,
what happened?
I'm like,
my career is going to be.
Don't worry about any of that.
Kind of better than ever.
Boots,
mom.
Yeah.
This is,
this is,
this will be a positive thing that
happens is I'm going through some shit
now just from like fucking my own
hoisted by my own petard situation,
like reading the news and all this shit,
but this will be a positive thing and
like I didn't expect them to sign it.
They got it in that.
I was like,
that's the end of that was just like the
facts of what happened.
Well,
you've got some things on your side.
You've got like tangible success point
was like,
oh,
it seems like it's got some momentum
there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's gonna be hard to stop that train
with anything other than a real
catastrophe.
Oh yeah.
I mean the,
they also know that I haven't.
It's also very apparent in every article
that was printed or whatever that most
people are on my side so to speak,
and I'm a hundred percent confident.
I did nothing wrong from a human as a
human being or a comic,
you know,
like maybe reading the room would have
been a thing I did,
but I was like,
I was like,
I know these people.
These are my fucking brethren,
like I,
I like,
I fucking took calculus with you people
I know,
I know the kind of Shit that me and my
Asian friends and my Indian friends
we'll talk when we were in fucking
school like this.
This is fucking light work.
Right?
Right.
And so,
so maybe that.
But even then I'm like,
no,
fuck that.
I'm not going to fucking think about
that going awry.
You know what I mean?
But yeah,
it was,
it was crazy.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's an educational experience and net
positive overall without a doubt.
And it also gives us an opportunity to
make fun of these kids,
which I think they need.
They need to realize that the world
thinks they're fools in the eye.
And I really believed that all.
I've read several articles on your case,
your situation rather your case caught a
case like a comedy me to,
you know,
all the articles that I've read were all
essentially positive and they were all,
you know,
mocking these fucking little children.
I want to,
I want to say for the record that eyes
on the record,
I still think that it was,
I still think that it's the minority of
that group,
especially at Columbia for sure.
Sure.
You know,
like it's just that they happen to like.
Because the majority of the kids were
like amped and like had a good time and
even if
that can happen though word,
some majority,
a majority can like you in a minority
can stand up and then the majority
doesn't do anything about it.
Yes,
go,
that shit hurt my feelings.
No,
no,
no.
Those kids,
those kids saying like,
let them stay,
let them stay.
But it wasn't like a chorus which is,
I would have hoped,
but I'm,
you know,
they're a little fucking babies and they
need to hear it.
They need to hit it a little babies
because that's how you grow up.
You know,
you,
you do something ridiculous and that
people criticize you and then you
realize,
oh,
I'm kind of ridiculous.
Let me just check myself.
Than it hurts your feelings and you
fight it off for a little bit.
You try to pretend you battle it,
but overall over the course of time
you're going to absorb that information
and hopefully those kids are going to
grow and mature.
I mean I have friends that were like
completely progressive,
Weirdo,
crazy off the charts like activists 10
years ago and now they're like way,
way mellow and they've just like,
what was wrong with me?
I was virtue signaling I was trying too
hard and they realized like the,
a lot of what they were doing was just
wasting energy and it was just,
just a lot of angst and a lot of just
trying to,
trying to affect change in order to make
themselves feel better,
you know what I mean?
Trying to push buttons in order to
validate their existence.
That's what a lot of that,
that specific.
I felt like it was like it was either
like a note.
We have an opportunity to assert our
sort of rightness,
however wrong it is here and this is,
we're going to take a stand and this is
who we are.
You know,
just just chill.
Yeah,
chill the fuck out.
What the fuck?
Yeah,
it's,
there's a lot of foolishness,
but this is the world we live in and I
think there's a big part of that
accentuated by the fact that we have a
maniac for president.
Yo.
Yeah,
water is because
they feel like that eval needs to be
combated at every turn because we didn't
before and we let this guy get into
office and now here he is and the
Mueller probe and all this fucking
craziness.
When Obama was president,
she felt a lot cooler.
Now it's like trump is president.
Everyone was like,
oh shit,
man.
Bunker down.
Now we realize all you have to do is be
popular and you can be president.
Like that's insane.
Yeah.
I used to be.
You had to be qualified.
We used to think that you understood
national policy,
foreign policy,
you understood defense.
You understood exactly what's going on
with the economy.
Basic English.
Yeah.
That guy doesn't know shit.
He's just trying to make buddy.
And wouldn't you love to be a fly on the
wall?
I would.
Cause what we're getting all the crazy
is him when he knows cameras are on him.
Oh yeah.
I would love to see what he's like
alone,
like what I would love to see him like
watch Fox News.
I like to like sit in our cheeseburger
just fucking crazy.
He's a crazy person.
It's really weird,
man.
It's,
it's unnerving and that's what I think
like what a lot of what we're seeing on,
especially with this particular thing is
the thing where it's like you don't have
control in any other facet of your life
necessarily,
so you're going to try to exert it in a
way that you think is positive when in
fact you're doing the opposite of what
you,
your,
your liberal sensibilities are.
Yeah.
I think it's also a trend and I think
that political correctness and it comes
in waves and it existed.
It was pretty,
pretty strong in the eighties.
You know,
political correctness was washing over
people in the eighties and destroy rap
and shit coming back and it'll go away
again.
People get sick of it and it'd be
ridiculous and people will rebel against
political correctness in it,
but I think overall the culture is
trying to adjust,
is trying to self adjust.
We're trying to the the actual culture,
the as a whole is trying to eliminate
racism and eliminate sexism and
eliminate bias,
which are good noble goals.
They're good noble goals,
but along the ways you have these polar
extremes of people that are doing it
wrong.
Poor execution,
terrible execution level understanding
and it's also strange to me,
it's like what utopia are you trying to
create by silencing stuff?
Because just because you do that,
just because you say,
oh,
you can't say racist shit doesn't mean
it goes away.
Or you can't say sexual shit doesn't
mean it's a.
that's more like you're treating the
symptom and not the disease.
Right.
But in their defense,
jogging my very specific platform.
Right.
This is a stage.
If you had actually said something
actually racist,
then it would make sense that hey,
we don't want anybody telling racists
100 percent.
Right?
Yeah.
So they.
But they wanted it to be racist.
Yeah.
That's the thing.
It's like you just fucking take a
minute,
take a second to relax and once I get
it,
is that what utopia
have you read about that's ever been
real?
Like every book we read in high school,
College,
brave new world,
Lord of the flies,
19 eight or animal farm like the giver,
we were in fucking middle school.
That's all a utopia but this fuck that
fucking killing babies and you know,
goes south.
It's all a fucking false utopia kind of
situation.
There's,
there is hate speech in the world.
One hundred percent.
You know you don't want it on your
platform,
but you've got to decide what is hate
speech,
when is it really hate speech and when
is it just ignorance.
And sometimes the best way to combat bad
speech is to let that speech play out
and let good speech overwhelm it with
logic and reason and a better argument.
That's really what freedom of speech is
supposed to be all about.
That we work all this out.
As soon as you start censoring voices
and telling people that you're not going
to allow them to talk,
boy you,
you,
you start,
you create this atmosphere where you can
start to choose what you're going to
allow through and when you're not going
to allow through and then you're going
to start censoring things that are far
more subtle.
You're going to start censoring things
that they don't seem reasonable,
but you've decided that it's already
okay to sensor,
so you've censored this person nagging
to sensor the next worst thing.
You're going to go down the line until
it's just people that disagree with you
and then you're like,
oh,
well my world is perfect now,
when in fact,
it's actually just a bunch of people
that are talking shit about you.
You just don't happen to know about it.
Are you familiar with what's going on
with Patrion with A.
No.
There's a bunch of podcast pay for him
or you can pay for shit with Patriana.
Well,
yeah,
you can pay for things,
but it's not necessarily just for
podcast,
but people do use it for podcasts,
but they use it for many things.
But there's this guy,
his name is Carl Benjamin,
and he goes by the name of Sargon are
our cod,
and he considers himself a,
would you call a classic British
liberal,
which is more leans,
more conservative than our idea of what
a liberal is,
but essentially it's more of a liberal
libertarian.
Toward what,
how would you,
how would you describe a classic British
liberal?
Like what would be the definitely google
that first of the name would be Carl
Benjamin.
I mean,
that's a strong name.
Well,
Sargon of a cod.
His,
his,
uh,
his screen name and he has a youtube
channel and uh,
he said something on a podcast,
not even his own.
He was a guest on another channel and he
said something about white supremacist.
He was talking about these white
supremacists that are acting up and
doing all these horrible things.
And he said,
and this is,
it's a poorly formed thought.
But what he said essentially said was,
you guys are being niggers almost.
You act like white niggers.
This is his word.
Jesus said,
this is what he's saying.
You're acting like a bunch of niggers.
Just so you know,
you act like white niggers.
I'm sorry if you heard that word and so
finding you right now ladies and
gentlemen,
I'm just reading a set exactly how you
described black people acting is the
impression I get dealing with the.
All right.
I'm really,
I'm just not in the mood to deal with
this kind of disrespect.
So that's a very fun,
very.
It's a very poorly thought out way of
expressing himself.
That's what I'm thinking.
I'm reading this and I think also
sometimes people like using that word to
shock and they think they can get away
with it and you know when you're using
it,
what's this,
what's this?
What's the context of this is it.
But it also said,
here,
look,
you carry on,
but you don't expect me to have a debate
with one of your faggots.
Like why would I bother?
Okay.
Now that is more egregious because that
is.
I mean if you're just dealing with
censoring words,
there's not.
He's not using that saying you're acting
like the way you call gay people.
He's not saying that.
He's like calling someone a gay slur.
He's saying,
and again and again,
so this was just what they had decided
to use.
Now I don't agree with any of these
things.
He said,
this is what I'm reading this.
I'm like,
this is,
these are poorly thought out arguments.
This is a poorly thought out sentence.
It's not,
well,
just stop scrolling there for a second.
Put that back up.
It's not,
it's not well thought out.
Not at all.
Not Good.
So they've.
But this has nothing to do with his
patrion page isn't even having to do
with his,
his channel.
This is something he made this comment
as a part of a longer wide ranging
interview with a youtuber name Michelle,
Katelyn,
and you can watch the full interview on
this says chatting with Sargon of a cod
about the liberalist community.
Um,
so he,
you know,
it was free flowing.
Many set a bunch of really stupid things
that.
But what he was trying to say is that
these people are behaving exactly the
way they do when they try to say racist
things about black people.
Essentially they're behaving exactly the
way they're describing.
Yeah.
Race in a racist way,
it's just not well thought out.
I mean like this guy needs a class and
how to fucking be articulate.
I mean Jesus Christ,
but that's,
that's what I'm getting from this.
Patrion decided to remove him because of
that and there's many people that feel
like that's not exactly why they did it,
that they were looking for an excuse and
it's really because his anti liberal
bias.
So they were.
A lot of people are disgusted by the
idea that Patrion is now censoring
voices and the deciding who should or
should not be able to receive donations
from their fans based on their own
personal political.
So this is the argument now and it's a,
it's an interesting thing that's popped
up because people like Sam Harris who is
very left.
I mean,
he gets accused of being all right,
was kind of hilarious,
but he's very progressive and you know,
he's a public intellectual and he's
decided this is a moment where he is
going to pull his patriotic account down
because he doesn't like the way they are
choosing to censor people and d platform
people based entirely on something that
has nothing to do with anything he's
done on their platform and it's
something to do with something that was
out there on,
on another channel.
So it's one of those weird little battle
ground situation.
But I do think like,
uh,
the patrons a private enterprise,
right?
Yeah.
So they can do whatever the fuck they
want and essentially they can and did.
So then people can decide that they
don't want to deal with Patriot because
Patriot doesn't support free speech,
free speech.
The argument would go that free speech
is not just supporting speech that you
agree with for true free speech is
letting people express themselves right
now,
the way he expressed himself,
they're not very good.
Clumsy,
right?
Heavier.
That's an understatement though.
Like your thoughts on it this year,
you've never seen this before,
what are your thoughts on it?
I'm like,
dude,
I mean it's such a bad choice of words
is such a way to just.
If I'm,
if I'm person reading that,
unlike my immediate,
my eye goes,
you said what you can't.
Like,
it's such an offensive word where you
can't even go there immediately
distracts from the point that you're
trying to make.
So it's a good way of putting it.
You know,
it's,
it's such like a just needed you need
like I don't think that guy,
I don't know if he's racist or not,
but like I don't think he is,
but your immediate reaction is like this
guy,
you can't do that.
You have,
you have fundamentally destroyed
whatever point you were trying to make
because of your choice.
It's like a,
you could be trying to save.
I can't think of the analogy now,
but like it's,
it's such a distracting choice of words.
Yeah.
That's a great way of putting it,
you know?
Yeah.
It's like if he could have said,
and by the way,
like all conversations,
including this one,
right,
like I'm trying to formulate these
opinions on the fly.
So are you.
Yeah,
that was what he was doing on the fly.
I don't think there's anything he
prepared.
So I think that damn dog,
I mean that wasn't vetted.
He's gone over that with a fucking
highlighter.
That is the key points.
And once I hit on had been a few
websites.
I don't know,
I was trying to look up the ones
exactly.
But I know for instance,
on twitch,
uh,
in the last year they've changed things
on the terms of service that kind of
what you do broadly,
yes.
Affects what you do on anyone to catch
the problem with that.
What you just saying right now is the
guy who's the CEO of Patriot actually
went on.
Dave Rubin's show,
the Rubin report and said that they're
only concerned with things that
happen on Patrion is that,
that's what they focus on.
Then they changed that after this
because here's the problem,
like I see their point with this,
this particular thing that this guy
said.
I see how they find that offensive and
if that becomes a thing that he does
more than once and becomes a thing that
he uses that all the time and uses that
kind of that kind of language in that
context a lot.
It's like,
hmm,
this is not.
It's clunky.
It's not.
It's not a wise choice of words.
It's sloppy and it's kind of a lazy.
Right,
and also it's kind of racist,
but it's why is it racist was racist
because what he's doing is attacking
people who are racists by saying,
and he could have done it this way,
right?
He could have said,
you people rally on about black people
and call them this and you say they're
doing that.
This is what you do.
If you are exactly what you're.
The only thing that's missing is that
you don't have the right pigment to,
to receive your own hate,
your own self hate,
but you're doing the very things that
you accuse that you in a racist way.
Cues black people doing.
It's stupid though,
but it's to the way to combat that.
I don't you,
when you start censoring people and
taking away their ability to make a
living by expressing themselves,
I just don't think that's the way to go
because you're just going to receive
backlash and that's,
that's the thing.
It's one of those that's,
that's one of those instances where it's
like you've set a trigger word that is
clearly a trigger word and and what you
just said is the way he should have said
what he wanted to say.
Right.
And in hindsight,
if you gave them an opportunity like
you've said,
Hey Carl,
here's a time machine.
Go back right before you said that,
and say it again.
What
I'll just say on Patriot on the,
like I'm reading their stance on it as a
website.
They don't host anything,
so like to say that it's something
that's happening.
Do blogs like Jordan Peterson wrote a
blog on Patrion,
but that's what most of their content
is,
is links from other websites they have
to take into account what you're
creating as a creator
anywhere almost.
This isn't even him as a creator though,
this was him,
a guest on someone else's show,
so this is not something that's his own
content that he
put out their stances that he
collaborates with other creators and
this.
This would be considered a
collaboration.
Yeah,
that's a generator.
I guess I see that point.
I do not think that it's a wise thing to
censor him though.
Do you
get that motherfucker,
a PR coach dog with Jesus Christ the
very least.
Maybe this is the first dance,
which I think they're saying it is a
definitely a warning or maybe thing.
Man,
here's the van.
Temporary bandmates,
but
here's the thing.
What he does is he's a.
he's.
He's a commentator.
He sees life and he talks about it and
I've listened to a lot of his stuff and
it's very good.
He's a smart man.
A lot of it's very good.
This is not very good.
So the right way when it comes to these
things is let the people who contribute
to his patron decide that they don't
like what he's doing,
so they're are no longer going to
subscribe.
That's the correct use of the platform.
The platform exists because people who
are fans are able to contribute that.
I say to mash,
I really liked what you do.
I'm going to send you a $100 every
month,
and if someone wants to do that,
they can do that,
and there's a lot of people that do do
that.
When you say something that makes them
offended,
that makes them realize you're sloppy
with your words,
that makes him feel like you're a fool.
I go,
you know what?
I'm not sending that fucking guy money
in the marketplace talking sense,
and then they pull back.
If he lost 30 percent of his market
because of that,
and then a bunch of blogs are written
about how stupid what he said was,
that's the correct response.
Correct.
I think I don't think,
but the problem with pulling out is then
guys like Sam Harris or pulling out and
they've lost somewhere around 20 percent
of all their patriotic counts because of
this.
Oh,
she does.
There's been a backlash and by the way a
backlash that's primarily coming from
people who don't agree with what that
guy said,
but do agree that it's a very slippery
slope to start censoring people.
That's a good moral stance to take like
a.
it's like Kinda like I forget which
political figures set as I do not agree
with what you're saying,
but I will defend fight to the to day,
ability to ability to say yes.
I think that's important because the
only way that ideas get worked out is
through discussion and as soon as you
silence voices,
then you no longer have that discussion.
Now to youtube credit,
he still up on Youtube.
Okay.
Because this was a talk that he had
that's available on Youtube.
You can listen to it on youtube.
He still has his youtube account and
he's still able to,
you know,
the,
some.
One of the things that we're seeing with
D platforming is it's sort of a
cascading effect.
So a dominoes twitter takes you down and
then facebook takes you down with a guy,
a limbo,
but some other right wing or that got
like a said some shit.
And then Gavin McInnes proud boys.
Got To tick them off of everything.
Yeah,
he's off everything.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's that.
And with him it's even,
what was he?
He's like a hate speech guy,
isn't he?
He's like fucking inciting violence and
whatever.
He definitely did incite violence in
that he wanted these proud boys to fight
against Antifa and he felt like the
Antifa people were thugs and that they
showed up a conservative events and they
threatened violence and then he wanted
the proud boys to fight them.
I actually had him on my podcast long
before any.
This shit went down when I didn't even
know what the fuck the proud boys was
and I was asking him.
I knew him as the co founder of vice and
I know knew him as what I would
basically say is he.
He was essentially,
who's a shit talker,
who's a provocateur.
He was a clever provoca tour and it was
kind of a funny guy like he came the
last time he came on the show,
he was dressed like Michael Douglas from
falling down.
He had the fucking briefcase and
everything and the crazy tie and yeah,
I mean he's doing,
but he did it on purpose.
He said he's dressing like Michael
Douglas from falling down.
Like he's,
he's a guy who would trick people into
coming in and talking with him on his
youtube channel and they thought that he
was liberal or progressive and then he
would,
you know,
he would basically talked him into a
corner.
Barry Cohen,
shit or leg,
you know,
in a way.
Yeah.
He was doing a lot of that and there was
some of it was very clever.
I was doing on his youtube channel.
Then he got into this whole proud boys
thing and we.
There's a video you can watch the
bizarre origins of the proud boys from a
podcast that I did with Anthony Kumina
from opiod Anthony,
and he explains how the proud boys.
Initially we're just a joke.
It's a joke.
It was literally a joke and they did it
to make fun of a guy that was one of
the.
Was one of their interns think so it
sounds.
Yeah.
It's kind of a crazy story,
man.
That shit took a real life of its own
and now they're fucking junior kkk.
Exactly.
That's crazy.
They,
they,
they all of a sudden it got away from
him and they became an organization
where you could just join,
so all these people joined and then they
act as a proud boy and they were beating
people up and all this other crazy shit
and he doubles down.
He got out,
he quit.
He denounced his position that he
realized that his life was falling
apart.
He was being labeled.
As you know,
he.
They falsely claimed the FBI labeled
them as a hate crime,
but they didn't.
But the southern poverty law center did
label them as a hate crime and several
other organizations as well,
but the southern poverty law center,
they've had some pretty crazy shit that
they've said as well.
There a serious,
a liberal progressive organization that
occasionally oversteps the boundaries of
logic and reason they,
but he.
What he did was start an organization
and I had a joke about about vegans.
My joke about vegans was the problem
with vegans is a problem with any other
group.
If you get a group of 100 people,
what are the odds that one of them is
going to be a fucking idiot?
Well,
that's 100 percent right?
If we're being really charitable,
one out of 100 is a fucking moron.
So if you get a group like vegans,
which is anyone can join and you have,
there's 300 million people in this
country,
that means there's 3 million fucking
idiots.
That's generous and a lot of them are
Vegan and the joke was that the problem
is not the actual people with good
ethics and morals don't want animals to
suffer.
The problem is you let a bunch of people
with no identity join your gang and then
they become a part of this plant based
gang.
This is same thing with the proud boys.
I think some of them probably went into
it thinking it was a goof and they were
going to go there and they thought these
Antifa assholes,
these 90 pound dork swinging bike locks
at people and calling everybody a Nazi
and fascist and trying to shut down
every single conservative speech.
That was at a neat.
Any sort of university.
These people were preposterous.
They were calling Ben Shapiro and Nazi.
He's a fucking Jewish man.
Wears a Yarmulke.
I mean,
it's crazy to call him a Nazi is
completely insane.
The alt right and the left almost.
Exactly.
And so their idea was to have something
that would be there to balance out the
alt left and it got out of control and
so he denounced it and he stepped away
from it.
Pulled with,
but it's too late.
He's,
he's now what you sped.
See you don't know him,
but you said he's the hate speech guy.
You said he's that guy.
He's that.
Hey,
that's how everybody's going to see him.
So if you found out your sister was
dating and people like what you're
dating,
the hate speech guy,
like that's who he is.
And he's like,
no,
no.
It's not that.
It's like it got away from him.
It just became this.
It wasn't him anymore.
With all these people that joined it
were actual racist.
Too late.
It doesn't matter too late.
There's no room for that in this world.
I'm out the game.
Yeah.
So any.
All these other groups have.
Once he started getting deep platformed,
these other groups got pressure to deep
platform him because they said,
hey,
you keep the hate speech guy.
You're telling me that hate speech guys
on Youtube.
And they're like,
fuck,
okay.
We got to take them off.
And so that this domino effect does seem
to take place.
So with this Sargon of a cod thing
though,
it doesn't seem to be taking place with
him because people are examining what he
said.
And they're saying,
well,
this is a sloppy use of these words.
It's not wise what he did,
but I do not think he's a racist.
And I don't think he was promoting
racism.
What he was doing was he was using words
poorly.
Awfully.
But yeah,
I mean that's what he's guilty of.
Yeah,
the but that's the,
I mean that's a,
that's a good sign.
He's not being deep platform.
Then if like if people are taking a beat
to realize like,
oh I don't hate gays and blacks.
That's,
that's the point that the whole,
this whole thing has been a lesson in
patience and that's good to hear that
like this guy is being afforded some
patients about,
but in their defense he's already been
kicked off twitter.
He'd been kicked off of twitter before.
I don't know what for though.
Do you know what he got kicked off
twitter for?
He got kicked off at twitter previously,
so he already had that scarlet mark,
you know,
there was already.
People are already looking at him.
I mean he's been inarticulate on twitter
before.
No way get it on.
I don't know what he had done it.
He had determined that he had harassed
somebody.
What's that?
This could be a new account.
I guess they seize on it right now.
Is it a new account?
Might be how many followers you have?
13,000.
Yeah.
It's probably knew you had a lot more
than that.
He must have.
I'm wondering,
you started a new account,
her permanently banned account.
Let's see.
Yeah,
he's permanently banned.
April of 27.
Oh,
so it's pretty old.
Funny.
April of 2017 is millions of years ago
now.
The new cycle so fast.
It's too fast.
It's weird,
right?
It's,
it's dude.
I'm telling you.
When I was at the shows like a story
would be hot Monday morning and then
Tuesday morning I was like,
what happened?
No one gives a shit.
Dog gives a shit.
That's one of the more interesting
things about this whole trump story with
the,
especially the Mueller probe,
is that there's been so many of those
quick stories that have just piled up.
Like you remember that family where the
son died in Iraq and he didn't mean to
cut you off.
He was.
He'd said something.
He had marked somehow another mock the
family and people like this guy and it'd
be in a lot of people thought that was
going to be the end of him and it's just
like these things sort of pile of the
Pakistani American.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah,
and there's been so many of those
stories that.
But accumulative,
they are starting to pile,
it's just little much is little drops
that are coming in the lead.
He can.
He's been able to sort of roll with
those punches and just sort of slide
them off kind of.
But this Mueller thing,
what I really like about the Mula thing
is that it's been a real slow build and
you get little hints of what's going on,
but it's been like the,
you know,
where you're talking about this at the
show while I was there.
It was just like FBI don't fucking.
They build a case.
Yeah.
They take their fucking time and they
got all the time and money in the world
to build.
And when they come they don't come like,
yeah,
it's not like a,
they come a heavy the,
the knocking on doors that come in a
hundred deep and that's what it's going
to be.
Zero to six.
A 100 like.
Yeah,
like that.
And that's going to be interesting to
see what happened.
Especially Mueller.
You look at that guy is I calculated
assassin that isn't.
He is taking his fucking time.
That's got to be killing trump.
He doesn't take shit and that the beauty
of it Mueller,
that he,
you know,
he's an independent guy.
Yeah.
He don't take shit from nobody.
Well,
the crazy thing was that trump was
literally considering firing him.
Yeah.
But everyone's like,
someone was like,
hey man,
you,
you cannot do that.
That's why you can not do that.
That he fired comey.
That's when I realized like,
wow,
like this guy could just do that and he
could just fire the head of the FBI
testing.
He's just going to do this.
Can I get rid of the Attorney General?
That I think was supposed to be on my
side but sessions.
But he finds out,
oh no,
jeff is also.
There's races as he is,
as a man of high ethical standards when
it comes to like,
I'm not gonna fucking dude.
I'm,
I may hate minorities,
but I respect the law.
You know,
like that's,
that's jeff session.
Did you find out
what happened?
There wasn't a really good explanation
of it.
It was just one of those things like he
had a.
I think he even had a debate with baked
Alaska and then the next day he was gone
with no real explanation of why he broke
the prototypes.
I'm anti Sam and Shit Baked Alaska
Alaska guy.
He's the guy is a meme guy.
It was just a meme guy,
but now he's essentially become this
like really
right wing,
uh,
sort of,
he's,
he's kind of in the info wars camp as
well.
Right.
But Baked Alaska is come up with some
fucking hilarious memes.
Memes are hilarious.
He had one with uh,
Alex Jones has always had a bunch of
them like that.
I've been out the game for that,
like the meme game.
That's all of it.
Like,
um,
so I feel old,
you know,
interestingly,
what is it saying far right?
Far Right.
Neo Nazi,
what?
He's a neo Nazi,
bumble kind of name is Anne and dma and
t kind of a name.
The frau
proud puts though.
Alright man,
let's wrap this bitch up.
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
Overall,
man,
I think you handled this really well.
Thank you very much.
This is definitely a positive for your
career.
Thank you.
Funny Dude.
You just continue to keep on moving on.
Thank you man.
I appreciate you brother.
My pleasure.
Thank you.
Thank you too.
Thank you man.
Oh,
tell people how to get to your
instagram,
your twitter,
all that jazz.
Yeah,
sure.
I'm at finding the Mesh on instagram.
Twitter.
I have like 10 followers because I hate
twitter.
And then um,
I'll be,
I'll be at the punchline in Philly
December 27th through December 29.
Beautiful.
Go there and snatched the mic from you.